Oboro reveals at just how much weight  she's dropped since joining weight  watchers a year ago I've lost over 40  pounds I can honestly tell you I  struggle no more I've eaten everything I  love tacos pasta I've never felt  deprived I would say to anybody who's  thinking about joining Weight Watchers  take the leap and get about the business  of enjoying a fantastic and full life  that's o's latest ad for the company we  were just with the star in november and  we gotta say she was looking super trim  back in the spring as she opened up to  ET about her experience with Weight  Watchers I feel like it's a program for  life for me and it's all I can say is  it's working  I still love bread I still eat it every  day  just not alone  [Music]